[Music]  well it's said that Santa can speak any  and every language and that proved to be  true at this very special event in  Maryland deaf and hard of hearing  children had the opportunity to visit  and communicate with Santa using  American Sign Language something one  mother says is incredibly special for  her son who is deaf  and allow my son to communicate directly  it's just amazing and he can actually  sit there and talk and laugh and tell  stories and  really connect with Santa and when I saw  that it made me emotional  can only imagine well according to the  website  startasl.com there are around 50 000  people in the U.S and Canada using  American sign language as their first  language